[Applaudissements]
j'ai 13 ans je suis sur un terrain de
basket à boston je joue contre un joueur
qui est plus âgée et qui porte au pied
la toute première paire de air jordan il
me mets au défi de le battre pour gagner
sa paire malheureusement malgré tous mes
efforts je perds le match car il était
bien plus fort que moi
avant de partir il me dit et max tu
n'avais aucune chance de me battre
mes baskets font partie de ma
personnalité elles sont le prolongement
deux mois même à 3 de trouver ta paire
ce jour là j'ai compris qu'il ne
suffisait pas d'avoir de belles baskets
aux pieds mais qu'il fallait surtout les
incarner comme beaucoup de choses dans
la vie du haut de mes 13 ans j'avais
trouvé ma quête
juste une précision quand je vous parle
de sneaker je vous parle pas de ça on
est bien d'accord je vous parle plutôt
de ça et ça vous connaissez avez vous
déjà associés les mots culture et
sneakers
quand on parle de culture on pense aux
arts aux lettres au théâtre comment
imaginer qu en vous parlant sneaker je
continue à vous parler de culture
savez vous qu'il existe plus de 200
définition du mot culture
autant vous dire que finalement chacun a
la sienne
me concernant j'ai construit ma culture
me passionnant pour les sneakers et en
définissant leur ancrage avec la société
contemporaine bien au delà du sport ceci
n'est pas une chaussure de sport ceci
est une culture 1968 jeux olympiques de
mexico
cette année là les médaillés d'or et de
bronze sont deux athlètes noirs
américain tommie smith et john carlos
mais à la surprise générale au moment de
recevoir leurs médailles
ils se tiennent sur le podium en
chaussettes la tête baissée
le poing levé quand et de noir leurs
baskets des pumas suède sont posés sur
le podium à côté du en refusant je dis
bien en refusant de se présenter avec
aux pieds il envoie un message fort au
monde entier leur volonté rappeler la
condition des esclaves noirs qui allait
du pied ce geste contre le racisme et
l'exclusion dont ils sont victimes aux
états unis fera scandale
ils seront bannis des jeux olympiques
est interdit à vie de toute compétition
c'est ainsi que la puma suède devient
symbole quasi révolutionnaire suis-je en
train de vous parler de sport ou 10,3 de
société d'appartenance d'individus deux
peuples je suis d'origine
afro-caribéenne j'ai également vécu aux
états unis cette anecdote historique a
donc une résonance toute particulière en
moi vous savez nous avons tous des vécus
des origines les sensibilités et des
centres d'intérêts différents
alors je vous le demande quels sont les
vôtres
y at il une chance qu'il soit relié à
l'histoire d'une sneakers répéter avec
moi ceci n'est pas une chaussure de
sport ceci est une
merci aujourd'hui les sneakers sont
partout elles ont quitté les terrains de
sport pour envahir nos deux récits
nombreux sont ceux qui ne les voient que
comme des produits de consommation de
masse et non comme vecteur culturel ou
identitaire alors la question peut se
poser
subissons-nous ce phénomène de mode dans
le public
qui a des enfants de moins de 7 ans vous
les reconnaissez mes filles en sont fans
vos enfants je suis sûr ont les mêmes
chez vous est possible d'échapper aux
sneakers cars reine des neiges et autres
basket qui clignotent
oui c'est vrai de qualité médiocre
fabriqué en oeuvre en asie elles ont une
durée de vie ultra limitée vite acheter
vite consommée je le reconnais il est
très difficile de résister aux
marchandising des marques qui dès leur
plus jeune âge cap leurs futurs
consommateurs et pour les parents qui
ont des ados la question stickers est un
sujet très sensible
les sneakers mignon cars reine des
neiges vont laisser la place à d'autres
idoles que son pharrell williams ou
rihanna qui ont carrément leur propre
collection dans des maisons comme adidas
ou puma
du coup je suis sûr que vous avez passé
des après midi entiers avec votre ado a
trouvé le bon coloris d'une conversion
star ou d'une paire de stan smith je
sais je crois avoir compris toutes ses
pairs ne sont pas identiques
il faut trouver le coloris que les
copains n'ont pas cessé crucial alors en
sorte votre ado s'affirme il sait ce
qu'il veut
même si quelquefois ses motivations peut
vous paraître obscur ou futiles
détrompez vous
malgré la pression sociale les
phénomènes de mode et une apparente
uniformisation
il est question pour lui d'infirmation
de soi de construction de son identité
d'appartenance un groupe est en même
temps de démarcation à travers une paire
de sneakers
il construit sa propre culture
paradoxalement ces jeunes consommateurs
ne connaissent pas grand chose à
l'histoire de ses pairs
1917 j'ai bien dit 1917 naissance de la
conduire seule star avec plus de 800
millions de paires vendues à ce jour
cent ans après sa création
savez vous combien de paires sont vendus
chaque seconde trois paires idem pour la
stan smith vous la croyez américaine et
ben pourtant elle a été conçue en france
à strasbourg en 1964 supervisé par le
tennisman français robert haillet elle
s'est d'ailleurs à pleslin robert
haillet pendant de nombreuses années
avant d'être des baptisés en 1978 pour
s'appeler la stan smith qu'on avait jugé
beaucoup plus vendeur que le nom
franchouillard robert ailleurs récupéré
par la rue la stan smith va devenir une
paire emblématique du mouvement hip hop
quand je vous dis que ceci n'est pas une
chaussure de sport et que ceci est une
culture et pourquoi pas une contre
culture
vous l'aurez remarqué ce sont souvent
des personnalités des mouvements à
contre-courant en rupture avec les codes
de leur époque qui est souffle le
changement la sneakers n'échappe pas à
ce constat
car si elle s'est sortie des terrains de
sport poussé poser dans la rue c'est
principalement grâce au hip hop un de
guam subversif ces artistes qui disent
trois rappeurs danseurs graffeurs arbore
un look radicalement différent sneaker
au pied 1986 marque une rupture
le groupe de rap américain ron m6 or un
morceau intitulé my adidas qui met en
avant les adidas superstar la marque
adidas malgré elle se retrouve propulsé
en symbole de la street culture
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est lors des
concerts du groupe du 3ème si le public
ceux des choses pour brandir ses pairs
d'adidas
oui c'est curieux la sneakers à ce
moment là devient l'étendard de toute
une génération en rupture avec son
époque
la jeunesse va adopter progressivement
les codes du rap du hip hop et du
streetwear
vous l'aurez compris dans les années 80
j'étais ado et comme des milliers de
jeunes je n'ai pas échappé à la règle
ça c'est très important à savoir disons
donc que le rap a popularisé et
urbaniser le port des sneakers
je suis sûr que pour beaucoup d'entre
vous depuis les années 2000 le vendredi
au boulot c'est friday res knickers au
pied et que pour d'autres c'est même
cinq heures au pied tout le temps pour
autant on est loin d'expliquer ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui le phénomène
stickers car si le hip hop à populariser
la culture sneakers michael jordan en a
fait un mythe
vous connaissez peut-être des amateurs
des passionnés qui sont prêts à tendre
10 heures voire dix jours pour acheter
le dernier modèle pour être honnête avec
vous j'ai fait partie de cette
communauté 1990 je suis en vacances à
san francisco lors de la sortie de la
jordan 5
l'atmosphère est tendue l'ambiance est
électrique
tous les passionnés veulent leur père
cependant le nombre d'exemplaires
disponibles à la vente est très limité
aux abords de certaines boutiques des
débordements éclate je réussis avoir une
paire dans une petite boutique
mais au moment de sortir de la boutique
le vendeur me contrait à cacher ma paire
dans un sac neutre et opaque de peur que
je me fasse braquet et il avait raison
je n'ai pas pu porter ma paire pendant
plus d'une semaine le temps que les
choses se calment
croyez moi sur parole on dépouille ait
des gens pour une paire de sneakers
voire même plus
l'engouement était tel que le très
sérieux magazine de sport américain
sports illustrated
deux titres est à propos de cette jordan
5 youzhny coeur on you life vos baskets
ou votre vie cela m'a tellement marqué
que lorsque j'ai enfin pu la porter elle
est devenue ma paire celle qui fit le
lien entre le jeune garçon de 13 ans que
j'étais qui étaient émerveillés par joie
qui portait la jordan une est l'homme
que j'étais devenu qui âgé aujourd'hui
de 45 ans portent fièrement c'est jordan
5 comme le prolongement de moi-même à
bien me chercher on a tous une histoire
avec une paire de sneakers en quelques
minutes
je vous ai parlé de faits politiques
d'histoire de sport et d'éducation
j'aurais aimé vous parler de design de
cinéma de technologie il n'y a pas un
seul de ces domaines qui ne soit marqué
de l'empreinte du sneakers et pour ne
pas finir tous comme des moutons en
basket
s'il vous plaît encore une dernière fois
ceci n'est pas une chaussure de sport
ceci à tulle je vous remercie